j'écris très activement je peux dire
travail me suis enfin approprié lecteur
média je ne veux pas je veux que tu veux
mais je me sois tranquille ne peut pas
s'attaquer
je suis vraiment pas voir ta carrière
je promets que je le défendrai pas je ne
veux pas qu'à gagner ma part je me dis
je vous connais je vais taper fort du
homard mal voilà tout chef mais je ne
veux pas hésité à faire les affaires
comme ça vous démange bavure elle
partageait pas le coup je suis touché je
les regarde se passe de shawn heins
gauvard bon c'est une carte sim san
antonio estrada et ses soutiens françois
bozizé
signalez vous tombez nez en fait on
change tout on en fait éventé du jour
ses deux seins et un visages autour
non mais ça le mec il hier un peu comme
ça tu essaies genre totalement nadine
sait pas faire la demande
j'avais des cheveux une photo je passais
par là mais ça
non
car de l'intérieur
des stars et moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une technique aussi reconnu
mathieu de leur montrer mais c'est bon
je te dire vous venez à l'essai
ses capacités n'ont jamais fait mais
c'est moi il dit
[Musique]